anybody meet the old-fashioned way kept
calling anybody right that's what's up
you didn't grow anymore
what would you say to earth girl drunk
girl in a bar now you still together how
long that's what the [ __ ] is up judge
that all you want to I'm engaged you
know I met my fiancee she had a fat ass
and I followed it is like one of those
viral videos with a wank Romanenko
harassed and now this my fiancee No oh
that's bad listen why women complain
about a lot of stuff and that's the most
ridiculous is this cat calling video
because it's like yo that's how your
parents met not mine my parents met at
the wedding but yours
[Applause]
I'll be hearing these stories
monban how'd you guys meet well your
father harassed me
non-stop for a couple years and
eventually I relented and here we are
that's love that's old-fashioned no this
is not come on that's not fun there's no
romance in that still drunk huh drunk
again anybody wants to take her from her
man this might be the time all right man
see you guys in five years engaged
married doing any of that
engage there you go me too that [ __ ] is
fun to say right fiance I like saying
that why you don't have to look at him
for confirmation why do women always
want Connelly through shows women look
at their men to see what they should be
upset about it's never I never see like
I'll make jokes about you know
girlfriends cuz you know their pains in
the ass and every time I look out in the
audience the woman is not enjoying
herself or like she won't like be like
and then just look at her man to make
sure he's not happy about someone else
saying something in comedy show you're
happy I know you said that like oh it's
like you got Stockholm Syndrome
okay I am happy I'm happy while she's
here when she cleans on your media
honest truth blinking hard at me
understanding I asked how is it being
engaged and instead of answering me she
looks at this [ __ ] and again
this time I know it goes listen I've
been in a relationship long enough to
know about a car fight and I know a car
- Bruin anytime I ask a couple of
questions
kids on one of these it better answer
that [ __ ] is one correct response out of
a thousand and anything else she's gonna
find something and then he can't even
enjoy the rest of the show because the
whole time he's like this [ __ ] yell at
me in the car and now I just turn it
will fight in four hours